so here's the
oregonian what happened is in
uh north portland which is the fifth
quadrant
of portland there was a confrontation
in north portland there was a
confrontation and what apparently
happened
is that a driver who claims he did not
know
that there was a protest going on uh
drove his way
into a weekly protest and this is a
protest that goes on without
permits or anything you drove into this
protest
and was immediately challenged
by protesters now the weekly protest is
to get quote unquote justice for patrick
kimmons who
was killed by police in a confrontation
in which he had just shot
two people and then came at police
pointing
his gun at them and they shot him 12
times and he died
do we know what justice would look like
it it begs the question a weekly protest
to get justice in the case of a man who
was shot by police under circumstances
that i think and it's not as if this is
simply the police having declared
the shooting justified there is video
from two different
angles of this shooting you can see it
yourself and in fact
zach do you want to go to the other
article on the
yeah the video from the other article
would be good
so anyway it's not the most beautiful
video in the world because
uh yes because it's uh graphic in its
content and because it's surveillance
video so you know some sort of cc tv
thing um
so he's about to come running
you can see the police over there on the
right you can see
kimmon's in the circle running at police
gun out they
shoot him there's video from the other
side so this is a
thoroughly documented instance in which
a man
who happens to be black is shot by
police having just shot two people
and threatening the police but the but
the man who was shot had just shot too i
just shot two people
um so you know but that has nothing to
do
with what happened last week what
happened last week was in the middle of
a weekly protest in support of justice
for the guy who was shot by police
well but it does have something to do
with it in the sense that you have a
weekly protest and in that weekly
protest
you had people brandishing
high powered rifles so this protest
contained people walking around with
high-powered rifles now i should point
out in some sense
the reason that i want to raise this is
that i have the sense
that you know uh evergreen was a
cautionary tale
for portland and portland's a cautionary
tale for
at least the west coast if not the
nation that we are
headed into very dangerous waters
now it happens that the guy who drove
into this protest had a weapon
now i think that weapon was a handgun
and i believe it was loaded
with some sort of non-lethal ammunition
that's how it's described
by the oregonian but he was armed
and these protesters were armed with
incredibly high powered weapons
now probably all of that is legal
because there are two ways that those
weapons
in the hands of the protesters could be
legal oregon is an open carry state
portland prohibits the carry the open
carrying of firearms
but if the people who were carrying the
firearms
had a concealed carry permit
then the prohibition does not apply to
them and if the weapons were unloaded
it does not apply so wait if you have a
concealed carry permit a prohibition
against open carry doesn't apply to you
doesn't make any sense correct are you
serious i i'm quite
maybe i misunderstand the law but i
believe that this is the way the law
reads so
the idea is the state of oregon allows
open carry and it has something called a
will issue
oh so but portland doesn't unless so
basically the state law overrides the
city law yeah oh okay okay
um so in any case i can't say that any
of these weapons
that showed up at this confrontation
were illegal if they were either
unloaded even though it was in portland
where open carriers
uh prohibited if the people who were
open carrying had
a concealed carry permit then they are
exempt and if the weapons were unloaded
then they would be legal so
nothing says that this was inherently
illegal but what is clear is that this
is incredibly dangerous
that we are dealing with a situation in
which people
engaged in a what i would think
is a preposterous protest in the
interest of
justice where it isn't as you point out
clear at all what that would even
mean right these people are walking
around
with you know with the ar-15s in the
street
some driver who doesn't know that
there's a protest encounters them as
drivers will if you're protesting in the
middle of the street
he's armed suddenly he's surrounded by
people who have high powered weapons
i mean you know what has to happen to
recognize the danger of this
right this is incredibly dangerous so
anyway i
i just didn't see that that could happen
here in portland and
we could uh not comment on it
if i've misunderstood anything about
what's taking place
i'm sure people will alert me uh in
large numbers i would imagine sure
um but which is which is good when we do
actually get something wrong that we
hear about it from a lot of people
we don't get things wrong and we hear
about how we did we also hear about it
and sometimes sorting through those two
um
things can be difficult yeah i'm
positively in favor of the first one
absolutely i'm 100 it's uh it's just
it's it's harder to to
always know because we do get a certain
amount if you got this wrong it's like
no actually your argument doesn't make
sense
the guy in the vehicle at the north
portland protest was beaten nearly to
death by the armed protesters
and there's a there's a link yeah i know
he's hospitalized
um still um it's a
it's a disaster yeah and that actually
that is quite an omission from what we
said
uh i was not sure what his condition was
i still i'm not sure i did know that
he's still hospitalized so
whatever happened was severe but yeah i
think we should have said more about
that and it just
didn't get said but we'll amend it here